JJ BEHRENS: Hi.
My name is JJ Behrens.
And I'm a developer advocate
at Google.
And I'm here today to talk to
you about using YouTube for
your business.
So YouTube for your business.
I want to answer a
few questions.
First of all, why YouTube?
And then I want to help
you guys get into the
right state of mind.
I'm going to show some less
technical examples and then
some more technical examples.
And all along the way, I
want to show you guys
how do you do that.
And then finally, since Google
I/O is right around the
corner, I want to talk about
what's coming up next.
So first of all, why YouTube?
So think about the number of
views YouTube gets per day.
It's actually 4 billion
views per day.
Next, think about the number of
mobile views that YouTube
gets per day, you know, people
watching YouTube
on their cell phone.
It's 600 million
views per day.
And that's actually up three
times since a year ago.
Think about the number of video
uploaded to YouTube
every single minute.
It turns out that 60 hours worth
of content is uploaded
to YouTube every minute.
You might wonder how
we scan for porn.
Well, actually we hire interns,
and we have a large
room with monitors all
the way around them.
And we play all that content
at the same time.
And the intern, if he sees
something bad, he
just points it out.
Not really.
So think about the percentage
of views coming
from outside the US.
It's actually 70%.
So YouTube is actually
a global phenomenon.
So now let me help you
guys get into the
right state of mind.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING - "ENTREPRENEUR
STATE OF MIND - THE NEW DORK"]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JJ BEHRENS: So you might
be wondering what the
heck did I just do?
I mean, I'm showing you
guys this video.
So actually, that's an ad.
And if you look at the metadata,
there's a link to
grasshopper.com.
So the interesting thing about
this ad is that it targets the
right audience.
when I was a start-up
guy, I was in the
market for a VoIP solution.
And that video gets people
like me excited.
And it reaches people like me.
And so the core take-home
message is Be clever.
YouTube is a great place
to advertise.
So I have another example from
Original Skateboards.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So Original Skateboard spent a
lot of money on traditional
social media.
But they found out that using
YouTube to connect to their
community actually worked
out better.
The way it works is this.
You create some good videos,
and then you
put them out there.
And you let people watch them.
And then when the users
comment on them, you
interact with them.
So Original Skateboards found
that by creating a community
and interacting with their
community, they were actually
able to sell skateboards much
more effectively than just
dumping a bunch of money
on ads on other
social media sites.
So the take-home message here is
create interesting content
and then use YouTube to connect
with your customers.
OK, now I want to talk about
educating and motivating.
Salesforce.com actually has a
lot of videos on YouTube.
In fact, they have 3,000 videos,
14,000 subscribers,
and 8 1/2 million
views, in total.
That's roughly equivalent to 35
hyper-efficient sales reps
on the phone, according to the
Senior Director of Social
Market Strategy at
Salesforce.com.
YouTube videos aren't just
for YouTube.com.
You could also embed them
on your own website.
And this is a great way to
enrich your website.
Using a YouTube embed, you could
explain your product and
it's actually really easy.
So here we have an iFrame tag.
And this is normal HTML.
We have the source for
the YouTube video.
And if you take this little
chunk of code ad you embed
this into your HTML page, it's a
great way to bring some life
to your page.
When Google+ first came out,
I was checking it out.
And I'll have to admit
I'm a little bit of a
social media noob.
Things never perfectly
make sense to me.
But Google+ actually had videos,
and so I sat there and
I watched every one
of those videos.
And a lot of people like me
learn best when they're
watching things.
And so after I watched those
videos, I thought wow, this
really makes sense to me.
It's intuitive at this point.
And so I think that the
take-home message is if you
use videos on your own site, you
can really help the user
understand what you're trying
to convey much quicker.
So next let me talk about
user-contributed videos.
Instead of just letting users
watch your videos, you could
also let them upload videos
to your site.
This is a great way to drive
community engagement.
Best of all, we have an open
source project called YouTube
Direct that makes this
really easy.
YouTube Direct is a platform
for user-generated content.
It's open source.
It's built on Google
App Engine,
using the YouTube APIs.
And it supports both
web and mobile.
YouTube Direct has been used by
a number of news agencies,
such as the New York Times, the
Washington Post, the San
Francisco Chronicle,
and so forth.
POV--
documentaries with a point of
view-- used YouTube Direct to
solicit video uploads
of adoption stories.
So imagine this.
You have a website, and
they want to solicit
user-generated videos.
So you use YouTube Direct.
And users can interact with
your website by uploading
stories about themselves.
This is a great way
to increase the
richness of your site.
So YouTube Direct also has
an Android and an iPhone
application.
This is great, because it allows
users to upload videos
to your site from their
mobile phones.
Let's get a little bit
more technical.
You could control the player
using either JavaScript or
ActionScript.
And there's even a Chromeless
version of the player that
lets you completely take control
over the viewing
experience.
Let me show you an example.
Gaia Online integrated with the
Chromeless player in order
to create a custom viewing
experience.
Video DJs--
or VJs--
are able to curate videos for
other users to watch.
And users can watch those videos
from the comfort of
their own home synchronously
on separate computers.
Now let me show you an example
of using the JavaScript API.
The goal here is to play a
video for six seconds.
We have a script tag here
that's part of an
overall HTML page.
Here we create a new player
called player1, where we
handle two events-- the
onReady event and
onStateChange event.
When the player is ready, we
start playing the video.
When we have a
playerStateChange, StateChange
such as when the video starts
playing, we set a Timeout that
will be called later.
When that Timeout is called, the
stopPlayer function gets
called, and we stop
playing the video.
Now let me talk about the
backend APIs for YouTube, the
GData APIs.
Using the Google.
APIs, you could upload videos,
search for videos, rate a
video, like or dislike.
You could comment on a video,
add a playlist, retrieve an
activity feed, retrieve video
analytics, order a beer-- only
if you have the special license
key for that one--
and more.
Best of all, using OAuth2, you
could do all of these things
with the user's account.
Now let me show you an example
of using Storify.
Five When you use Storify, you
try to tell a story using
different social media.
In this case, the story is
"Can Twitter Save a Dying
Language?" We see here various
blog posts and images, as well
as a tweet.
And then, finally, most
interestingly, we see a
YouTube video.
Interspersed is a
bunch of text.
So the nice thing is you don't
have to try to tell a story
just using one form of social
media, but instead you could
mix and match.
Next let me show you another
application--
memoLane.
memoLane is a curation app for
your digital memories.
Like Storify, it integrates
multiple data sources, such as
Twitter, Google Maps,
and YouTube.
memoLane takes multiple data
sources and overlays them on a
single timeline.
Here we are looking at Eric's
digital memories.
We see images, a tweet, Google
Maps, and a YouTube video.
Best of all, these are all
overlaid on a single timeline,
so even though we have multiple
data sources, they
come together in
a cohesive way.
Now let's get a little
bit more technical.
I want to talk about
Google Data APIs.
We make use of a range of
REST-based protocols, such as
ATOM, JSON, JSON-C, and RSS.
We have several standard feeds,
such as Top Rated, Most
Viewed, et cetera.
You could download user's
playlists, subscriptions, and
upload feeds, as well
as user's comments,
his profile et cetera.
And if you don't want to have to
parse XML directly, we also
have client libraries for
Java, PHP, .NET, Python,
Objective-C, and so forth.
Now let me show you
an example feed--
the top rated videos.
We have a URL here--
gdata.youtube.co
m/feeds/api/stan
dardfeeds/top_rated.
And we want to turn on
pretty printing.
When you hit this URL
with a browser,
you'll get an ATOM feedback.
So this is XML, of course.
Here's a feed tag.
We have an entry
for the video.
And each video has
its own entry.
Here's a video ID, the
URL, and a thumbnail.
Using all of these you could
put together a custom
application, using the
GData API, that shows
the top rated videos.
Now if you don't look forward
to parsing XML by hand, we
also have several client
libraries.
Here, let me show you the
Java client library.
Here is an example of using
the Java client library.
Here, we create a new YouTube
service, and we pass in our
developer key.
Here, we create a video feed.
And we could pass whatever
video feed URL we'd like.
Here we print the video feed
out, and we loop over all of
the video entries.
The sample applications that
come with the GData API have a
full rundown of how
to do this.
Next let me talk about
another application--
the History of Jazz.
The History of Jazz is
an iPad application.
They call it a coffee table
application, because it's so
beautiful, you want to just put
it on your coffee table
and let users pick it
up and play with it.
What's interesting is that
this application teaches
people about the history
of jazz.
It's got beautiful pictures
and music, and it's a very
immersive experience.
What's interesting about this
application is that they have
monetized it very well.
First of all, you have to
buy the application.
And second of all, they have
iTunes integration.
So if you like any of the music
that you're listening to
while using the application,
you could buy the music.
Now, let's not forget
about video games.
Video games could play videos.
They could upload video
game plays to YouTube.
And you could even use them
to create machinima.
Let me show you an example of
what I'm talking about.
Team Fortress 2 is
a video game.
And Valve Software decided to
have a contest for this video
game in which they awarded
prizes to the most interesting
videos that people could create
using in-game footage.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MALE VOICE: In a land without
law, one man will make a stand
in the name of justice.
And his name is El Muchacho.
XLR 105 Production presents
El Muchacho.
Coming to a theatre near you.
Valve Time.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JJ BEHRENS: Let me show you
another example of machinima,
this time using PlayStation
@ Home.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING - "ALORS,
ON DANSE"]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JJ BEHRENS: Now let me talk a
little bit about stuff we're
launching at Google I/O. Now
I know some of you might be
watching this after Google I/O,
so the good news for you
guys is you could just go
watch those videos now.
But for those of you who are
watching this before Google
I/O, I'm sorry.
You have a few more
days to wait.
Do you want to hear from and
see your site's community?
We'll be sharing a new
way to solicit
videos from your users.
Come and learn about how it
was developed and see an
example of it put to use as
part of the YouTube Direct
open source video submission
platform.
The next talk is YouTube API
plus Cloud Rendering equals
happy mobile gamers.
Many console developers already
incorporate video
recording and uploading directly
into their titles.
However, uploading to YouTube
from a mobile game presents a
unique set of challenges.
We'll present a new Google
compute-based architecture to
support mobile gameplay
video rendering.
Come and learn how the YouTube
API combined with cloud
computing can help enable
video uploads
in your mobile game.
Next, we'll be talking
about new YouTube
Android player tools.
If you're building an Android
smartphone, tablet, or Google
TV application, and you'd like
to incorporate YouTube video
playback into your application,
this session will
rock your world.
Next up, we have a Codelab
called Master the Latest
YouTube Data API.
The YouTube Data API is
changing, and we're ready to
give you a preview.
We'll show you the backend
infrastructure that is used to
power the new APIs.
And we'll show you the next
generation client libraries
that you'll be using to
build the YouTube
applications of tomorrow.
If you've made it this
far, I'd like to
thank you for watching.
If you'd like to learn more,
go to youtube.com/dev. If
you'd like to follow us on
Twitter, our Twitter handle is
YouTubeDev. Finally, on
Google+, my profile is
gplus.to/jjinux.
Thanks a lot.